cuanto se tarda en cruzar el océano con
el viento
hoy en día con el avión en unas 68 horas
se llega a las américas hay que también
suma un día dos de jet lag
pues bien yo salí de españa con la
intención de llegar a brasil hace muy
poquito y tardamos 20 días fueron 20
días en los que nos ayudamos de la
corriente y el combustible era el viento
fueron 20 días navegando navegando por
el océano atlántico a bordo de un velero
eso sí cuando nosotros llegamos ninguno
de la tribulación sufrimos de jetlag es
el sol el que marca el ritmo navegando
hacia el oeste son unas seis o unas seis
mil kilómetros en los que cada 34 cuatro
días se retrasa una hora el reloj
pero realmente qué es lo que viene a la
cabeza cuando veis esta imagen de un
velero
vida para unos pocos inaccesible quitar
estas regatas donde aparece el rey en
televisión
o ahora que llega el verano también el
salto al agua ibiza cervecita pues bien
el velero ofrece muchísimo más es muy
versátil y hoy vengo a presentaros la
otra cara del velero la de la vida a
bordo si os fijáis en este mapa
que recuerda a las rutas que hacen los
aviones todos los íconos están sobre el
agua ya sea río ya sea el lago ya sea
mar océano son barcos alrededor del
mundo el icono morado son los barcos
particulares son personas que están
viviendo y viajando por el mundo a bordo
de un velero personas que han decidido
hacer de su casa flotante un hogar
para mí esto hace cinco años no existía
yo no sabía que había gente que viajaba
así ni siquiera que vivía a bordo
fue tras la carrera de arquitectura que
decidí tomar un tiempo y salir a buscar
nuevas experiencias estilos de vida
diferentes personas con otra perspectiva
en la vida el mundo del velero ni me lo
planteaba más que nada porque es que no
lo conocía
pero este viaje que realmente no tenía
destino concreto ni objetivo real
el objetivo que era crecer como persona
como no tenía demasiado presupuesto lo
que hice fue ir uniéndome a proyectos
colaborativos por el mundo en uno de
estos me comentaron la posibilidad de
poder llegar a américa con un barco y
dije bueno un barco como puede ser esto
para mí me sonaba como ir a la luna
entonces decidí plantearme en canarias y
me dijeron sí sí tu pregunta seguro que
puedes encontrar un barco para mí
realmente lo que me importaba era llegar
a destino no sabía lo que significaba lo
de viajar en barco entonces me planté en
gran canarias tenía mucho tiempo y fui
de barco en barco me recorrí todos los
puertos poniendo carteles en cada bar
hablando con todo el mundo y a las tres
semanas encontré un barco tres semanas
buscando
y me encontré con jerome jerome era un
capitán de barco que estaba trasladando
su empresa desde el mar rojo hasta el
mar caribe su empresa era su barco y él
aceptaba tripulantes para la travesía
oceánica pero por qué porque acepta un
capitán personas en su barco no porque
nosotros no bueno la mayoría no teníamos
experiencia un barco cuando hace una
travesía oceánica en navega de noche
iría a las 24 horas del día entonces
tiene que estar vigilado constantemente
y una persona no puede estar sin dormir
tanto tiempo pues nosotros lo que
hacíamos era vigilar por las noches las
guardias nocturnas y también ayudábamos
en las tareas domésticas tanto la cocina
como limpieza
nos costó para que os hagáis una idea
unos 80 euros por persona sólo para
compartir los gastos de la comida es una
estilo de vida o no un estilo de viaje
bastante económico en el que tienes que
saber adaptarse muy bien y la verdad que
te juntas con personas maravillosas
porque estas personas que están viajando
a bordo son personas que ya han
realizado un cambio de vida que deciden
dejar su vida
la más rutinaria para vivir de una forma
más aventurera pues imaginaros este
viaje no yo
y comencé a viajar en el 2014 y desde
entonces desde ese primer cruce del
atlántico no he dejado de viajar en
barco para mí es el primer cruce el
atlántico marcó un antes y un después en
mi vida
en el viaje y sobre todo en la forma en
que tenía de ver la vida imaginaros que
estamos en el vierne europeo y salimos y
cruzamos el atlántico llegamos a turks
and caicos es un país que yo ni siquiera
sabía ubicar en el mapa y de turks and
caicos pasamos a bailar salsa en el
malecón de la habana a perder la
conexión en el 'triángulo de las
bermudas' a ver ballenas delfines en las
azores y de repente entrar en velero por
los canales de amsterdam cruzar el canal
de la mancha para llegar al comer fish
and chips en inglaterra y pasar
directamente a la mariscada el ribeiro
de galicia el fado en portugal la visita
de los delfines en gibraltar y luego me
veo bañándome en aguas cristalinas que
me recordaban tanto al caribe y
realmente eran baleares las calas de
baleares son preciosas y son nuestro
propio país que a veces parece que nos
tengamos que ir más lejos a ver estas
cosas
y por último el último gran cruce del
atlántico que he hecho ha sido
atravesando también el ecuador pasar de
hemisferio norte a hemisferio sur en un
velero
han sido ya tres cruces del atlántico
los que he hecho son muy diferentes cada
uno y en total aproximadamente en
viviendo temporadas en el caribe y
mediterráneo unos 25.000 millas que son
50.000 kilómetros todo por mar
esto aparece mucho cuando cuando se
habla así pero yo creo que cuando entras
en un campo nuevo siempre descubres lo
que te queda por hacer
y estas son las rutas a nivel mundial
que hacen los boleros que utilizan tanto
las corrientes como los vientos
portantes los vientos que los ayudan a
no ir contra el viento y estas son las
rutas más comunes que hacen los veleros
este viaje es un viaje lento realmente
no lo comparas con la velocidad que
ahora tiene un avión o con lo que puedes
ir en coche cuando tú te subes a un
barco vas a una velocidad de bicicleta
aproximadamente son 12 12 kilómetros por
hora 15 kilómetros por hora eso te
permite hacerte una idea más real un
mapa mental de lo que es el mundo porque
la transición entre los países la
realmente la vives
los olores los sabores los acentos cómo
van cambiando los estás viviendo poco a
poco puerto por puerto y ciudad costera
por ciudad costera además que no
acostumbran a recibir turismo estos
lugares a los que accedes
y como es un barco por dentro es es como
una mini casa no tiene tiene
habitaciones tiene salón tiene cocina
yo prefiero llamarlo más como si fuera
un auto autocaravana por mar no en lugar
de carretera utilizas el mar como como
ve bueno para moverte y en lugar de
utilizar gasolina utilizas el viento es
un viaje muy sostenible en el que eres
muy consciente de los desechos sobre
todo y también de lo que gastas es el
espacio es bastante reducido se parece
mucho a estas viviendas que tanto se
hablaba antes con la crisis de 30 metros
cuadrados las viviendas mínimas
imaginaros unas 6 personas viviendo
durante 7 días en un espacio de 30
metros cuadrados desde la pared más o
menos ocho nueve y diez diez metros y
tres y tres de ancho este espacio
compartido durante siete días suena
quizás un poquito demasiado si nos
imaginamos estando en un piso de 30
metros cuadrados pero cuando tú miras
por la ventana qué es lo que ves en
ciudad
es otro edificio delante hoy es coches
contaminación ruido sin embargo en un
velero es completamente diferente tú te
asomas y tienes 360 grados para ti
puedes elegir la estación del año en la
que vivir si quieres vivir en un verano
constante vives el verano en europa para
luego pasar te al caribe si no te gusta
tu vecino te mudas de cala
y es la convivencia la convivencia es
clave las personas cuando entra en un
velero yo notado que se transforman y
dan lo mejor de sí
sí que es verdad que es muy intensa la
convivencia tienes que ser súper
tolerante y lo malo se vive muy malo y
lo bueno muy bueno es casi como un
reality show un gran hermano de esas 24
horas se viven se viven intensamente y
en cuanto a los recursos yo diría que es
casi como un volver atrás no es el
espacio reducido pero también el consumo
de agua y de electricidad está muy
medido esas seis personas comparten un
tanque como mucho de unos 300 litros eso
quiere decir que tienes poco más de como
una botella de estas por día y por
persona para higiene para lavarte los
dientes para ducharte para lavar los
platos en ciudad gastamos una media de
unos 130 litros por día y por persona es
bastante diferente y bueno es muy es muy
consciente de cuánto gastas no llegas a
ciudad y dices que el lujo no abro abro
el grifo y aquí tienes de todo en una
ciudad aquí aquí tienes poquito lo mismo
sucede con la electricidad dispones de
un banco de baterías
y hoy en día tenemos teléfonos ordenador
hasta los libros son electrónicos esto
todo queda relegado a un segundo plano y
realmente el con lo que te conectas es
con la naturaleza la naturaleza esto que
quizá hoy en día ya no es que no lo
tengamos en cuenta es que quizá lo
hayamos adaptado a nuestro a nuestro
ritmo de vida no sé si hay alguien que
sepa en qué fase se encuentra la luna
hoy si es creciente 100 luna llena tiene
una nueva y yo creo que te importa bien
poquito no a no ser que lo digan en
televisión luna naranja enorme y luego
pues lo mismo con el viento si hace
viento nos refugiamos en un bar si si
llueve nos vamos al cine o si queremos
seguir durmiendo utilizamos las
persianas como transición y no nos
enteramos de que se hace de día esto en
el velero es cambia completamente la
escala de valores cambia
es el el medio el que marca el ritmo y
nosotros los que nos adaptamos creo que
últimamente ya estamos viviendo muy en
automático estamos acostumbrados estamos
estamos durmiendo nuestros nuestros
instintos estamos dejándolos un poco
aparte para para vivir sin
preocupaciones por lo que suceda fuera
todo estamos protegidos y no me importa
mucho más de lo que nosotros controlemos
yo creo que esto quizás suena demasiado
no dices cómo me voy a meter un velero
si tengo que saber de todo no tienes que
saber a leer el mar a leer el cielo a
interpretar los fenómenos meteorológicos
porque es lo que determina tu de llegada
a buen puerto yo lo veo un poco parecido
a como cuando nos sacamos el carnet de
conducir
por primera vez te sientas en el asiento
y dices bueno y ahora que no entiendes
el coche miras por los retrovisores que
hago me pongo primero el cinturón no
sabes muy bien qué es lo que tienes que
hacer pero llega un momento que del
trabajo a casa llegas y no sabes cómo lo
has hecho pero sale todo bien pues lo
mismo sucede en un velero se trata de
horas de mar
yo cuando me subí por primera vez solo
veía cuerdas velas todo se movía la
gente hacía cosas y pero pero que tengo
que hacer y llega un momento que lo
asimilas el sincronismo tal es tal con
el medio con el velero que lo tienes
dentro no es tan tan difícil como parece
realmente
lo que sí es es un viaje es un viaje de
autosuficiencia total es un viaje de
aventuras es una vida de aventura
en el que todo se mueve tienes que
tienes que adaptarte ser flexible es una
toma de decisión constante
tienes que saber un poquito de todo al
menos un poquito de tres horas o al
menos aprender que no lo sabes aprender
de motores de reparaciones de
instalaciones hasta de problemas médicos
algo sucede en el barco y estás no
puedes bajarte de allí si alguien si
algo le sucede a alguien tienes que
saber cómo solucionarlo y luego es un
estilo de vida realmente activo no
descansas dicen que el capitán no no
duerme cuidado que se descansa no
siempre tienes que estar alerta pero
luego te regala te regala pues estos
baños de mar cada día por eso no
necesitas tanta agua llega un momento
que el que te la da al entorno las
costas de sol los amaneceres aprendes
tanto de la vida bajo el mar como en
superficie la visita desde el finés
no es única hay cosas que te vienen a
ver casi todos los diarios y luego las
estrellas por ejemplo hay noches de luna
nueva en la que el cielo está tan
estrellado me parece más blanco y negro
cuesta distinguir las constelaciones por
la cantidad de estrellas que hay en el
cielo estas imágenes por ejemplo son de
el volcán activo
[Música]
me contaron que existía un volcán y yo
dije cómo llegó a ese volcán era una
isla y qué es lo que es lo que
alquilamos un velero y esa satisfacción
que da de llegar por su propio pie a la
cima del volcán para verla la va a salir
eso sólo lo puedes hacer por mar y luego
el mundo del mar ya no son sólo comunes
sino que también crea unos hábitos
nuevos
yo en mi vida nunca había comido pescado
tan fresco como lo como normalmente a
bordo se trata de pescar limpiar y
directamente
5 minutos
y bueno realmente yo hoy quería decirles
aquí que a mí aún me cuesta cuando
cuento con el creerme el protagonista de
esta historia yo hace cinco años no
sabía navegar no tenía que existía el
mundo del mar y quería compartir
esta fantástica posibilidad de viajar y
vivir por mar porque se conoce muy
poquito tanto tanto entre viajeros como
por algunos navegantes también y yo
cuando cuando salí de la carrera de
arquitectura
lo que yo ya me había formado era
académicamente y yo lo que buscaba era
formación a través de lecturas y
vivencias vivencias en el mundo en lo
que yo quería era formarme de esa manera
lo conseguí lo conseguí de casualidad lo
conseguí porque hice caso al instinto
ese instinto que a veces te dice que no
lo pruebas yo no sabía lo que me paraba
era incierto total
lo encontré de casualidad de no saber
nada me hecho capitán ha sido como un
cambio de vida y eso es el intentarlo el
permitirte soñar y atreverte a
convertirlo en una realidad muchas
gracias